[Music]
all right so we had done an article
about this very recently there was a
slight update wanted to chat about it
plus we have two really really fun
friends in the room we have nick and
bart um so
wow
that was so funny that's so clever what
was that
you got burned dude you got that rbf
korean thing going on right now no this
is my sassy black lady face
oh really okay
all right okay so mr vince mcmahon all
right we had talked about him stepping
down from ceo for uh misconduct
allegations at the time
and the interim ceo that ended up
stepping in this place was his daughter
stephanie mcmahon
so she was now officially literally as
of not many hours ago he had formally
announced his retirement from the wwe
amid the scandal therefore
without saying it's confirmed it is
confirmed stephanie mcmahon dude had
some heavies on her dude [ __ ] nothing
we talked about the [ __ ] leche
duffels yes legend duffels that's what
you call them
that's a good one
why didn't you come up leche duffels
milk duds isn't as good huh no that's
very old and stupid shut your filthy
yeah just [ __ ] read the article bro
it says milk does an idiot
nice
right here dude
[ __ ] tan shirt boy shut up
i have one too
what was that we know what the
misconduct even was sexual
it was it was him who's laura nidis
again there's a disease
i'm fast today dude let's go laura
knight is that a professional wrestler
uh maybe but that's a bad name yeah
that's a really bad name but stacy
keebler fine as [ __ ] she had the longest
legs in the wwe keebler yeah she is
[ __ ] fine you know who stacy keeler's
right god the amount of nuts people
displayed because of her she's look her
up bro
did uh vince mcmahon burn all the diva
chicks is that what happened or groped
them so they're like 80 something he's
77. so he pretty much paid off there's
like multiple like multi-million dollar
like uh you know nba type things she's a
wrestler
dude yeah dude her special was the high
kick
her [ __ ] legs were amazing
she's all right and that was her stick
too she would like walk through the ring
all sexy and [ __ ]
amazing and step through with her long
legs that was like a real [ __ ] thing
should we just watch the stacey keebler
intro video oh yeah exactly
bro the old school wwe
like the diva [ __ ] was wild do you
remember they would just rip off their
tops out of nowhere that would be the
whole i would just watch it all the time
for that please i was like 11 watching
them do like strip shows and [ __ ] and i
was like i can't believe this is on tv
and this was with jack off so much in
the bathroom his dad would get mad at it
i got harry potter it was disgusting
yeah that was a real story my dad told
me i stopped jacking your hair
i pulled my calf
why is it a special position i don't
know because i would go on my toes i'd
do the michael
oh
because you know we talk about this me
me and david have a similar theory that
when you extend your quads
and do one of these you know like it
makes you bust faster
and i would do that in the shower all
the time i was like 11 or some [ __ ] and
one time my dad he even looked me in the
eye and he said it like from across the
stop jacking off he's like hey he goes
the water bill's high he goes nick you
got to stop masturbating so much and i
was like what no what are you talking
about and i ran into my room and i was
like oh god i was like mortified yeah
you just met him screaming into his
pillow you freaking eating
dude
in the shower it was all up here my god
does every guy here need material i need
material yeah these days i prefer
material it's so easy
because you'd have to download it for
like four hours and get half a table you
guys he's all like time to jack off
how do you do it
no he's like entering the matrix david's
like this
oh yeah baby give it to me right now
thumbs up i know come true we're
fighting up new things right now yeah
you're [ __ ] weird no you guys don't
have oculus
[Laughter]
mario just catches me like this
with the hands
just with the hair controls
you know how i used to hide my import
tuners
oh wow so and my mom and my mom's uh we
have yeah we had another bathroom right
in the front you know you know my mom's
house when you go straight and then to
the left that's where the bathroom the
other bathroom is so i was like [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] do i hide material in here
where i can just go on them oh i got
another stomach ache i guess i gotta go
go in the bathroom
and then i was like [ __ ] how do i store
this [ __ ] you don't have internet
there's no phones or whatever right and
i'm like [ __ ] we had like these stupid
ass magazines and then i found out if i
pulled the uh sink hard enough the
bottom cabinet came off the floor so i
started being able to like uh which
magazines wedge magazines in there and
so i'd be able to pull it out and i'd
have like a selection and then one time
our [ __ ] sink started leaking and i
was like oh my poor francine deep
[Laughter]
you know your parents knew exactly what
you were doing you had diarrhea 17 times
today
oh my stomach oh my stomach
oh my god you announced it to everybody
else oh my stomach i'm 14 years old so
horny
and he's walking in there with a raging
boner
or just from the bathroom ah my friend
cd
you got to be a little more secretive
bro sasha singleton
everybody needs material right before
they jack off huh you guys can't just
use your brain he's like hey i'm horny
oh i know this and you just jack it off
i used to all the way up until high
school it was just quick you guys bring
your phone in there [ __ ] well i mean if
you're trying to get it out in the
shower while you're there like sure but
i mean if we're oh it's
a whole ordeal so do you like light
candles and stuff i'm just saying it's
not a [ __ ] hole or no it's just a
[ __ ] phone that's already in your
hand no
what sometimes you just want to get it
in your pocket
no this is what you do okay you open it
you mind
and then you meditate and then you just
form thoughts so you're one of those
guys a sister and then just but
how long does it take for you to jack
off on a good day 30 seconds clean wait
why do you need to whip out your phone
then do you close your eyes do you close
your eyes david in the shower
you close your eyes i pass out dude i
just wake up the next day
in the shower
and i just wake up with a [ __ ]
curtain draped around he probably sees
it like queen's gambit where she like
sees the chest
have you guys seen the good doctor where
he [ __ ] just imagines equations and
[ __ ] that's what i do
i've had the oculus in my head for years
dude i needed nothing i just need to
look at a girl on the street and i go
got it
oh he's creepy no i'm not because i'm
not staring
that's a true spank bank that's a talent
he's perfect you might be supernatural
dude it's easy [ __ ] i just go watch even
with you
yeah you too late
you can't even excuse me
my stomach
my stomach
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and it was when ryan was like this
yeah i know that's right i know right
really
you can do that
you start screaming rising right out of
me
you're a sick [ __ ] david and i like damn
you guys never did it though because i i
was able to do that up until i
discovered porn
dude oh yeah when you don't have
anything yeah
always but how do you but how do you not
get distracted with other things exactly
it's meditation y'all i'm just saying
i'm a creature of habitat if it's
available it's like 4k is available in
like 10 seconds
it's right there
i got i paid for wi-fi masturbating is
such a like a utilitarian thing you just
do going in there to get the job done
right don't bring politics in here but i
can't get the job like even a boot camp
like when you get the everyone gets to
read the newspaper so we get caught up
with the world on sundays right when
everyone gets the newspaper it's like jc
penny
twin towers just exploded
everyone's ripping the [ __ ] in the
lingerie section [ __ ] sears
[Laughter]
uh sears they all got lingeries yeah
magazines were the [ __ ] because it's not
porn but it could be what is yeah that's
a magazine
it was porn for a very horny high school
asian kid i'll tell you that have you
ever met a celebrity that you used to
jack off to oh no well that is a great
question who did you make
jlo you met j-lo
oh how many times did you jack off to
her bro only like twice that's it but
you met jlo i don't think i really
jacked off her i know you were gay
i did jack i did jack off to jackie chan
yeah yeah i met him female female jack
jack who else does i met um a porn star
in a [ __ ] bar one time
and i remember i remember one of the
dudes in the group was like i recognized
that head and it was actually a porn
song a guy or a girl no is it
i feel like you would never ask anyone
else guy or girl why do you pick on
anthony so much he said he said hey hey
hey that's weird and i imagined a bald
head
i tried to have your back but yeah no it
wouldn't make sense you recognize the
back of a girl's head that's actually
popular culture to understand that she's
sucking dick or something do you know
those things back of that girl's head i
think it's really hard to recognize
someone from the back of their head what
are you talking about i could recognize
her from the background
my height bro no because you have a
island boy head that's why you [ __ ]
hi
what what's the job
in here bam in your face
[Laughter]
we didn't get a single piece of
information about this week's man out
yeah oh yeah what are you doing 77 year
old multiple allegations of misconduct
in the video
you